LOUIS GRAY: Welcome back to
Google Developers Live at I/O.
I'm Louis Gray here, with Daniel
Sieberg, my co-host.
DANIEL SIEBERG: How's
it going, Louis?
How you doing?
LOUIS GRAY: Excellent.
This has been an incredible
two days of jam-packed
content, pretty much from every
single product at Google.
It's been a lot of fun
to be part of.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah,
absolutely.
We're approaching the end of our
live coverage here, but of
course it will live on for
people to watch in many ways.
LOUIS GRAY: It's part
of YouTube.
And speaking--
DANIEL SIEBERG: And speaking
of YouTube!
Oh, what a segue.
LOUIS GRAY: Ah, who knew?
DANIEL SIEBERG: Just like
we rehearsed it.
LOUIS GRAY: So you
were doing the
YouTube Sandbox, yesterday.
You went and talked to
a bunch of partners.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's right.
LOUIS GRAY: We've already
talked about a number of
different products.
Give me an idea of what happened
in the YouTube
Sandbox yesterday.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So the three
partners we talked to-- one
from Korea called [? Wooa ?]
Brothers, which actually is
using YouTube in a pretty
unique way to get folks who go
to a restaurant and want to
share their experience and how
restaurants are using videos.
The second one is a company
called Capella Systems.
And they're offering a lot of
high-end production values for
producing video and
live stream.
Same goes for Mediastudio.
So those are the three
partners--
LOUIS GRAY: Excellent.
DANIEL SIEBERG: --and they've
got some really
cool stuff to showcase.
LOUIS GRAY: Great.
Well, thanks for the intro.
Let's go ahead and
roll that video.
Video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Hi there, I'm Daniel Sieberg,
with Google Developers Live,
here at I/O 2013.
And we're at the YouTube
Sandbox.
You may have heard of YouTube,
world's second largest search
engine, you might even be
watching this video on
YouTube right now.
And I'm joined by Ikuyo from
the Capella Systems to talk
about YouTube live streaming,
and how the software, and the
tools, that Capella Systems
makes available to people
really can add production
value to
what people are doing.
Talk to me about what you make
available to people.
-Yeah.
So Cambria Live is an all
software and supply solution.
So we integrate it with
YouTube's latest
API, version three.
So from Cambria Live software,
we're able to stream directly
to YouTube channels.
As you can see on the
[? target, ?]
if you have a YouTube Live
account, you can specify a
YouTube Live channel where
you want to stream to.
As you can see, that Cambria
Live can take
multiple camera inputs.
So right now, we're capturing
from our own PTIZ camera, and
importing directly to
YouTube channel.
So here, we're showing
a Cambria
Live Property function.
So we are showing-- we can
choose a different background,
as you can see.
Go and change the [INAUDIBLE]
image.
You can also select the video
footage to change to a
different background.
We are using a
picture-in-picture for this function.
So now that we see a lot of
shift towards IT-based
broadcasting.
So with the availability of
high-speed internet, and then
also open platform like YouTube
Live, anyone can do a
very high quality
broadcasting.
And Cambria Live allows users to
do that with just a simple
use of software.
-So you have an entire control
room, essentially, right here
on your computer, and more,
really, even more ability to
do those kinds of things.
Who are some of the folks that
you're working with?
Who really has an interest in
this type of technology?
-So we work a lot with live
events producers.
So any sports events.
Also, we have a lot of
broadcasting customers who's
doing a lot live streaming
to YouTube Live.
Or to their own Wowza or
other BBFS servers.
-And what's it been like
working with the
YouTube team, so far?
-It's been great.
It allows us to reach out
to more customers.
Not just broadcasters, but
customers like the sports, or
corporate, who's wanting to do
streaming but not necessarily
have a in-depth broadcasting
experience.
Cambria Live is very
easy to use.
Streaming to YouTube Live
platform, they're able to
reach out to more viewers, from
anywhere to anyone in the
world, so that's great.
-And just quickly, what is the
future of this technology?
Where do you see this heading,
down the road?
-I think that this is a new type
of broadcasting workflow.
We are definitely seeing a lot
of shift from traditional
broadcasting workflow, to more
like an IT-based broadcasting.
So I think that more and more
professional content holders,
or event producers, are going
to use this platform.
All very software-based
solutions, streaming to
YouTube platform.
-Cool.
Great.
Thank you so much.
And thank you to our gentleman
over there.
Thank you.
-Our model.
-Thanks very much.
-Thank you.
-All right.
All right, moving right along
now to [? Wooa ?]
Brothers, and I'm joined
by Dave from [? Wooa ?]
Brothers.
Now, [? Wooa ?]
Brothers is Korean.
Tell me what it means?
-It means "wow" or "elegant"
in Korean.
-Excellent.
Now let's talk about what it
does for folks in particular,
ties into restaurants, and how
people can upload their own
experiences at a restaurant
to YouTube.
And then restaurants
can also push their
own content to YouTube.
So walk me through
a demo, here.
-OK.
So we show all the nearby
restaurant.
First, you select your
category of the food.
As far as I know, you
like chicken.
-I would love some chicken right
now, I haven't eaten
lunch.
-So chicken restaurant around
here, Moscone Center.
You go through the list, see
what you like, click on the
restaurant information page.
And on here, you can check out
the introductory video about
the restaurant.
-So they've posted this video.
-The owner posts it
up on the app.
-And it could be showing some
dishes, or a chef, whatever it
is.
-Yes.
-OK.
-And underneath that, you can
also check out the user review
made by video, as well.
And if you like, you can upload
your own reviews on the
app as well.
-So this allows you to use the
camera in your device--
-Yes.
---to do a review.
Even while you're at
the restaurant.
-Exactly.
Yeah.
So Give A Rating, Text,
Picture, or Video.
Record like that.
-OK.
-So that's that.
-So it's very social way, and
visual way, obviously.
People like to share their
experiences with food and
their favorite restaurants.
-Exactly.
It's a lot more richer than
just a text and photos.
-OK.
So tell me, then, how
this all ties into
ordering food, as well.
-So we have two different ways
of ordering food through our
app, which is direct calling--
this is a direct call
to the restaurant.
Or you can complete your payment
on app, as well.
We call it [SPEAKING KOREAN].
So click on that.
Select the food you like.
-Yeah, I'm still craving
chicken.
-Excellent choice.
-Yep.
-Put it in a cart.
And you're ready to check out.
Continue.
And special requests--
we're just going to say Google
I/O for the sake of the event.
-OK.
So this would all be sent to
the restaurant itself.
They're going to get this--
-Yes.
---this order coming
in to them.
-Yes.
It would be on the receipt.
-On the receipt.
OK.
-And then put your points.
Continue.
-OK.
-Simple as that.
And succeeded.
And restaurant owner will
see that the order--
-It just popped right in.
---arrived in.
Let's go process the order.
I received your order, and then
I decide how long does it
take to complete the order, like
30 minutes, 40 minutes,
50 minutes.
-OK.
-I'll just say 30 minutes.
-And then the text message will
go straight to the user,
say your delivery will be on
it's way in 30 minutes.
-Great.
-And on here--
here's your receipt, with the
Google I/O and a QR code where
you can download our app.
-Now I just want the chicken.
-We made these badges for all
different food names in
Korean, since real food are
not allowed in most
[INAUDIBLE].
-Sure, sure.
-Just pick one, anything.
-OK, I'll take that one.
-That's chicken.
Perfect choice.
-All right.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate it.
All right.
Thanks.
And we wrap up by talking
to Media Studios.
And I'm joined now by Morgan,
from Media Studios.
Co-founder of Media Studios.
So talk to me about the
collaborative video production
that you can do with Media
Studios, but also connecting
people around a particular
project.
-Sure, absolutely.
So the goal of mediastudio
really, is to facilitate media
production.
The goal is to bring
Hollywood-quality production
to the YouTube ecosystem.
So we've done that by bringing
talent and connecting with the
workflow management
system and tools.
So it what makes it very easy
for anyone to come, find
people, or do the
work themselves.
So here are a couple of tools
that we've developed.
This is the subtitling tool.
So if you don't have a script,
the first part is you have to
create a script with
time codes.
So we extract the waveform from
the video, and make it
very easy through automation
to create your sync points,
where all of the subtitles or
closed captions would occur.
So this analyzes the waveform
and it would create the in and
out points automatically, where
someone can then go in
and transcribe their text.
Once you have the text, you can
assign it to a translator
through the marketplace.
So in this case, imagine
you would want to
have Spanish subtitles.
What we've done here is we've
integrated the auto Google
Translate API, where you can
just click a button, get an
automated translation.
If you like it, with one click,
you can use it, or you
can go in and actually make
modifications to it.
Since it's all connected, you
can actually monitor the
workflow through the Mediastudio
platform.
Another tool we've developed
is a rotoscoping visual
effects platform, where it
allows you to identify objects
you want to manipulate, either
remove, change the color.
So in this case, I run a
rotoscoping algorithm which
has identified by rows.
I can then segment it out of the
picture, and then go and
apply certain filters to it,
such as changing the colors on
the fly, so it makes it very
easy to change and enhance
your video through
the platform.
The goal is-- we have native
apps, but also to have
third-party apps, and create a
script-to-screen web-based
workflow for media production.
-And this is post-production
we're talking about, as
opposed to something
happening live--
-That's right.
-Yeah, OK.
And if somebody wants to get
help on a project they're
working on, they can actually
come to Media Studios and find
the right people to help
them with that?
-Absolutely.
You could start on your own,
and if you need help, just
basically post a job-- or
actually, run a filter on the
type of expertise you're
looking for.
We've recommended creators from
all over the world will
be presented to you.
-And working within a certain
budget, time frame?
-You can set the budget and
actually have people actually
propose their offers on
that specific project.
-OK.
And just quickly, what was the
experience like, working with
the YouTube team
on all of this?
-They've been very,
very supportive.
[INAUDIBLE] and Jeremy
have been terrific.
And they're really helping to
get this out through their
community.
-All right, cool.
All right, thank you so much.
-Thank you.
-That's going to do it for the
YouTube Sandbox tour, here on
Google Developers Live
at I/O 2013, and cut.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
LOUIS GRAY: Very cool stuff.
I mean, thanks a lot, Daniel,
for taking the time to go
through all those.
I mean, it wasn't just YouTube
who you talked to.
You talked with G+ guys,
Drive, and Maps.
What was the summary of your
experience talking all these
partners interacting with
Google services?
DANIEL SIEBERG: I think the
consistent message was just
that the experience they had
with the development team was
rated very highly
in every case.
Which--
I know that they're here at
this event, at our event,
essentially, and maybe they feel
compelled to say that.
But I got a sense that they
were totally genuine--
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
DANIEL SIEBERG: --about
everything that they were
saying about these
relationships, which is
critically important when
you're working with
developers.
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely.
That's something
you have to do.
If you're a developer, you want
to make sure that the
people who you're talking to
will give you the information
at the right time.
That the APIs that you're
working on will still be
there, in six months.
[INAUDIBLE]
And you get the kind of feedback
that continues to
iterate and make applications
and the platforms great.
Now, you'll notice, for those of
you watching at home, it's
gotten a little quieter here.
We're coming up at the end of
our programming on day two,
and it's the final time that
we'll be live streaming from
GDL at I/O. It wasn't too long
ago, a couple hours actually,
you should have seen it
when Bradley was here.
It was just--
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's
right, it was packed.
LOUIS GRAY: It felt like 1,000
people right behind us.
We were keeping them off the
rope, which was really fun.
We're really wanting to make it
known that we're doing GDL
really year-round.
GDL at I/O has been
a lot of fun.
It's been a pleasure to stand
next to you and do a lot of
this stuff.
But we're kicking off incredible
content when we
head back to all of our
respective offices, be you in
New York, or Mountain View,
London, Sydney, we're
broadcasting around the world at
developers.google.com/live.
There's hundreds of thousands
of people subscribed to
YouTube at Google Developers.
We hope you're one of them.
If you haven't done it already,
that's the best way
to really get the updates
coming in.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And we should
say that the content from
everything that we've talked
about today, all of these
segments, will live in some
form through the GDL site.
LOUIS GRAY: Not only will they
be on Google Developers Live,
every single video is going to
be Google Developers Live,
including all of the stream
sessions for I/O and those
that were just recorded.
And so there are hundreds of
sessions that took place at
I/O over the last couple
of days which
were not yet streamed.
And so we're going to take
those, take them from YouTube,
put them on Google Developers
Live, and make that really the
clearinghouse for all of I/O
and all of the developer
content that we can
get to you.
And help you do all the learning
that you need to do,
and all the training
that you do, and
have access to Googlers.
It's really been an incredible
opportunity to have that kind
of transparency that I really
enjoy about Google.
You mentioned that developers
need to be able to trust in
the code, and they need to be
able to trust in the company.
And I think that's something
that was a big deal, even out
of yesterday's keynote,
like we talked about.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yep.
Absolutely.
So, I know there's still one
more day left, but could you
pick a highlight?
Narrow it down to one--
LOUIS GRAY: Well, for me, the
highlight has really been
having that kind of transparency
and being able to
talk to the Google executives
that make it happen.
I mean, we really started
off with a bang.
Not just with a three and a half
hour keynote, who we did
we get right after that?
It was Megan Smith, Vice
President of Google[x].
She's thinking about things and
seeing things every day
that you and I, and most people
here and not here,
could only dream about.
DANIEL SIEBERG: The
moon shots.
LOUIS GRAY: The moon shots.
I mean, even for some of us
who live really close to
Google and see it, the
announcement of self-driving
cars, we're like, is
that even real?
We hear about Glasses, it got
written up in the "New York
Times", we're like,
is that even real?
I would love to keep feeling
like that, is that even real?
And I think we get spoiled here
at Google because we have
access to so many brilliant
people, so much scale, and so
much dedication to
really making the
world a better place.
Not just a better place to make
money, but a better place
to really have technology
that impacts everyone.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah.
And it becomes a conversation
here, where you get the
developers who can listen to all
of those folks at Google
and share all of their wisdom,
and then you get the Google
folks who can listen to the
development community in this
way that takes it off just
being connected to the
internet with emails, and
that kind of thing.
But actually face-to-face
meetings, and--
LOUIS GRAY: That's
an important--
DANIEL SIEBERG: All of that's
still so important.
LOUIS GRAY: I've talked about
that from day one.
Google I/O is an incredible
place for the thousands of
developers to see us
face-to-face, to engage with
us, to ask us questions.
Even Larry Page did
a Q&A, yesterday.
So we do want to hear.
This isn't just empty.
And Google Developers
Live is intended
especially to do that.
And so, when we're broadcasting
out of smaller
studios in Mountain View,
smaller studios in Delhi, and
Milan, and all these places
where our people are
advocating on your behalf as
developers to make incredible
apps for our users.
It is about that type of
transparency and engagement.
And even for those people who
can't join us live, we always
want to make sure those
videos are available
for you go and get.
And so it's really exciting to
have that Developers Live
site, where you go in and
go to the archives.
And if you're someone who's
deep into Chrome, you can
watch every Chrome event ever.
You can learn how to write your
first Drive app in C++,
or JavaScript, or .Net,
or whatever is
your language of choice.
And that's a really important
thing for me.
What really stuck out for you?
You got 30 seconds.
DANIEL SIEBERG: 30
seconds or less.
I'm a little impartial to GEOBE,
and I feel like I've
attached to that world.
So for me, the chance to now
talk about the new Google
Maps, which internally we've had
a chance to see for quite
a while, and now that this
is available and
out there for people.
It's just really exciting,
and I think that
there's so much potential.
LOUIS GRAY: And again, it goes
to moon shots and scale.
What has happened with Street
View, and Earth, and mapping
the entire globe?
It's just a really
incredible thing.
So thank you very much for
the thousands, and
thousands, of people--
DANIEL SIEBERG: Wherever you are
in the world, speaking of
Maps, all over the world.
LOUIS GRAY: And thank you again
for joining me on GDL at
I/O and for all the people on
the production side who helped
make this happen.
We've had an incredible
run of events.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah, we should
say there are a lot of
folks behind the camera here--
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely.
DANIEL SIEBERG: --who've
helped us out.
LOUIS GRAY: So definitely
check us out.
Developers.google.com/live,
we hope to see you there.
Talk to you soon.